I'm crying - glasses there was a human
being
hey what's going on everybody four first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions even hotter wings and today
I'm joined by DJ snake he's a bonafide
hit maker check his billboard stats you
can pick up his studio debut album
encore which is everywhere and available
now DJ snake welcome to the show and I
know good man how are you with hot food
my mom is like from North Africa so you
know she's always cooking like crazy
spicy so let me see how it goes you
ready to get going
[Music]
all right so the first one is sriracha
sriracha is no big deal
[Music]
so I want to talk to you about the
anatomy of a hit for a second don't
worry I'm not going to ask you to share
your special sauce but I do know that in
addition to hard work in addition to
talent in addition to that ear there's
always something that happens but takes
a project from here to here so what I
want to do is bounce some big DJ snake
hits off of you and you can kind of tell
me that thing that kind of bounced your
way turn down for what unexpected he
took like a year you know to really like
you take off and that was on the fan
clouds like for free randomly and after
that we saw like 10 min ratchet let me
love you you know I made the beat for me
love you like six months after Leon was
not supposed to be adjusting on it and
then he heard like the beat and the hook
and he was like I wanna do it and then
two days before like I was done I was
over the album was like finishing all
the records and then you send a vocal
like two days before the deadline
Wow so it's like really imma let like
that yes super super last minute that
was like yes so I talked about football
for a second because besides music that
seems to be the thing that sort of
courses through your vein up everywhere
you know that I always have a bowl you
know so on my own on my own ladies make
this book your writer yes you have a
soccer ball on your right yes sir
and then a couple years ago you hosted a
soccer tournament Miami with other DJs
which DJ's kind of impress you with the
way that they they could play out there
oh guy goes pretty good yeah I can't go
a surprise me
I was expecting this and then it's free
though II run this [ __ ] groans
for real
and then I'm not one to talk but I do
have one more athletic question for you
can you explain that jump shot that you
took that fastball shots that you took
I'm so bad at basketball oh my god you
know every time I'm trying to like to
play basketball and snapchat like all
the American people [ __ ] on me
[Music]
I still want to talk about the name DJ
snake for a second because it's not
every day that I meet an artist who kind
of represents his stage name like a bad
tattoo that I regret all you know my god
you don't like your name no I hate it
but if I have the origin story right it
does have a pretty amazing back story
come to my your early days as a graffiti
really you know we were trying to to be
a graffiti artist but I was just trying
to function up in Paris I was like 14
million my my my only friend we were
just like trying to put our name yo
focus [ __ ] yeah and then I start like
DJing and I wanted to come up with a
name I was like okay [ __ ] what do you
think you know it is interesting with DJ
names because I'm like which ones are
good like is Skrillex a good name is
Diplo a good name or any of these even
good name just nipples bad too so as
someone who spent the last couple years
touring the planet I'm sure that you
have kind of a unique perspective when
it comes to must visit destination so
what I want to do now is just take you
with kind of a rapid-fire with some of
my most pressing international travel
questions I'm good you know so please do
by live up to the hype yes I love to buy
this one of my first place in the world
I want to do buy like everybody Mighty
Mite seems like mine too
what's the biggest mistake that tourists
make when they visit Paris going to
Sean's illusion of nice because you
might get rough where is the most
underrated party city everybody talks
about Vegas everybody talks about it
bees is there one that doesn't get
enough credit I like Brazil a lot 10 the
fabulous nothing fancy you know this is
just vibes a few speakers a lot of
beautiful womans food gunshots sometimes
going to be to wrap up anger and not the
fake ones no and you know you don't
nobody like bring like phones because
they don't have phones all right when
they do like their own [ __ ] like
bring the phones every time so they just
dance you know all night long there's
real vibes you know there's only there's
only those on
it was [ __ ] me up so this is a hot one
saw on the hot one show okay but listen
if you don't like the sauce tell me you
don't like the sauce if you like the
sauce some of you like the sauce no
pressure I have it I like it it's cool
all right the next part this show is
called explain that gram and what we do
is we do a deep dive on our guest
Instagram pull interesting pictures that
need more context so I'll show you the
picture and then you just tell me the
bigger story now good yeah all right I'm
good right now we all do stuff you're
chilling yeah I want to talk too much no
because I might get [ __ ] with this [ __ ]
you and Taylor Swift
[Laughter]
that was the Grammy party somewhere in
LA you know now I know her like a little
bit better and yes super nice super
funny we talk about like everything
about Paris and she's cool I like her
shinato t-swift yeah when DJ snake & DJ
calendar face to face what sorts of
things you guys talk about you know we
talk about a lot of things you know we
were trying to understand like my world
because in you like all my records but
he didn't know like this festival things
no that's new for him so I was trying to
understand like the old thing we talked
about Miami you talked about like Hamas
this is an interesting picture you
encounter McGregor the Beast the champ I
love him he's a you know more of my
friend it's crazy talented he worked
works hard that was right after like
when you lost against yes we are the
soldiers more like no you [ __ ] lion
bro you lost today but your lion got to
come back you gotta shut that [ __ ] down
[Music]
yes I wanted to just like disrespectful
yeah [ __ ] should I drink like water Oh
milk so here's the deal once you're in
the terrordome
nothing's really going to save you know
what I'm saying DJ snake so you can have
some water it'll chill you out a little
bit people get very mad about water
people are like there's no cap station
and then like it's not going to down but
it is an ice-cold drink to kind of cool
you down temporarily huh the milk the
dairy kind of cuts the heat so yeah
let's see if it works for you I don't
like milk drew look but it's kind of
yeah my sudden any any port in a storm
so every genre seems to have its own
rules of engagement when it comes to
infighting you know and hip-hop you'll
have a diss track for example but an EDM
it's a little bit nerdy er there's kind
of like these twitter Wars there's the
wav file joke there's all those sorts of
things I kind of want to talk about the
anatomy of these sort of conflicts when
it comes to DJs
I like when deadmau5 like goes wild and
literally it's always fun to watch you
know or Diplo is good this was good too
we always like making fun of each other
you know like Kevin Aries on the low is
like super super super funny kind of a
savage on the low he's a savage
Californians [ __ ] Savage is crazy
but yeah you know I'm pretty cool with
everybody but you do do some pranks on
Dillon Francis every once in a while
yeah put like his number on the on the
screen on the big screen onstage at
Ultra you wanted to kill me he was
really upset really yeah wait you put
his phone number out there yeah cuz you
know you really like this number you
know that was like a pretty easy thing
to remember because the other source of
conflict seems to be when people are
biting you know DJ's get really about
I'd be by or - I did I did that to a
Putin I could get on blast
you know let's you know I feel bad
afterwards I was like dude [ __ ] this man
you know like I don't want to do that
anymore like [ __ ] you like if you copy
me copy me this is what it is you know
the relators is followers
[Music]
I can tell immediately listen I'm not
too proud to admit it these last three
or four sauces are outrageous I don't
know how I dug this grave for myself but
I did just week after week eating these
links eating this sausage all right so
my favorite thing that you share are
these sort of cryptic proclamations on
social media they're very drake like and
I mean that as a compliment but what I
want to do now is kind of give you some
of these DJ snake pronouncements you can
kind of tell me where your head was that
and kind of explain the bigger pictures
that sound good yeah ego is the root of
all conflict Wow this is true man for
real this is true especially in the
music industry like I could make like so
many records so much more records with
some of my friends but just because of
egos like we don't really [ __ ] with each
other anymore
this is probably my favorite one the
realest people don't have a lot of
friends it's true too many snakes shout
out all the chicks with big foreheads we
love you now somebody hacked my Twitter
the bomb
nah no it's that part of the that part
of the show yeah I remember like no
Noriega mm-hmm was going top one top one
top one is terrible why my only so DJ's
on the festival circuit they always
bring out guests but you seem to take
great pride taking a lap DJ snake jacket
is coming off cooling it down coin it
down well does rule crazy crazy it's hot
once they can't blame us for false
advertising
alright job tough flames we don't want
to kill you DJ snake Oh
is it getting worse
[Music]
yeah walk it out walk it out good tickle
laughs Wow
disrespectful Wow how can you do it now
you you're a liar bro there can we can
we can switch paddles if you want DJ
snake I'm I'm not going to sit here and
take that I'm not going to sit here and
take that kind of character
assassination
have you ever looks which whistle voice
yeah DJ Khaled adds the switch Bobby Lee
switched maybe DJ snake wants to switch
yeah this way hope you like it looks
pretty sure it looks superhero-like but
it's it the day in the left it's just a
day in the life I'm crying
mine is blesses there was a human being
you just sneak coming undone on hot one
five okay okay how much ever you are a
champ look at you and your back and your
back alright
so DJ's on the festival circuit they
like to bring out gas so you seem to
like an with you it's all right
you just have to hear me did they find
me through the hot sauce over here you
seem to be especially proud of the fact
that you bring out the sort of people
that no one are expecting you know you
like to bring out guests that surprised
the crowd there most notably the one
that sticks out to me is the DMX
performance we Coachella
a couple years ago can you tell me how
that came about and what you remember
about that day
I'm sorry DJ snake don't apologize we
could just interview you could just have
a nice chat but no like we have to bring
in spicy hot chicken wings oh my girl's
nightmare
so yeah DMX no okay let's talk about DMX
to talk about DMX so yeah I'm a big DMX
parent you know in the Ruff Ryders in
general I had a rest roomer on the same
show mm-hmm already booked so that okay
we got a new wave and then I gotta bring
like the legend you know G and we had
this you know and that was a crazy night
or Joshy Wow it's only like like drop
that [ __ ] Robby that was like a dream
for me you know I'm a fan of hip-hop you
know I grew up with hip-hop and being on
stage with DMX such a legend there was
like a lot of biggest moment in my
career
alright DJ snake it's an interesting
time we are to the mad dog 357 zone
having some trouble all did not expect
that go alright if you stay good bite
[Music]
whoa Center yourself if you get through
the bar might feel like you can hear
you're good you're good
I'm already going alright so for my
money there's no job with better perks
than an internationally famous DJ so if
you don't mind I do have a couple
questions about hotel suites and private
jets yeah [ __ ] this [ __ ] by the way
whoever created this man [ __ ] you mad
dog 357 don't ever come to Paris Wow
you're not welcome so you have a
residency in Vegas and I know that on
that night it's a work night for you but
let's say you're a childhood friend or
maybe like a new buddy or something what
does that Saturday night look like for
the people who are kind of just along
for the ride so first of all like I
always bring my friends from Paris one
by one like anybody does in that was in
prison in jail for like two three years
the first thing it does when you get out
golde just a yo I want to go to Vegas
cool I got you and then we bring them
and you know so every time I go to Vegas
I got my friends from like France
they're like oh she was there with this
oh my god I just Indies no it's always
like this so that makes me like realize
how lucky I am you know that one I don't
know about that one I have a show
tonight so
alright DJ snake it is tradition around
here to dab the last wing with little
extra players Megadeth sauce with liquid
rage you don't have to oh my god we
don't want to I know you have a show
tonight
you don't have to if you don't want to
be on a 50-100 be careful
[Music]
that's smart
more of our guys should do that yeah let
me let me breathe their complex the DJ
snake so what's a book just yeah you'll
never be the same
alright hunter boy there oh man oh man
what a comeback story all right DJ
snakes you're an earnest guy you came
from nothing you grind and you try to
inspire people who come from the same
humble beginnings so now while the death
sauce is creeping in on you it's finding
that spot in your soul I have to know
the DJ snake guide to success and
prosperity what advice do you have for
the dreamers out there so true yourself
keep believing making your vision don't
listen to nobody don't copy in our body
and
dog is walking those [ __ ] wings
that's probably the best advice we've
ever had on our wing 10 finale DJ snake
you made it through it wasn't easy but
you probably feel better for it
maybe maybe News r1 hey I got you I got
you I don't yeah don't worry we got you
ahead take it
take the table we got you an extra but
you know how it goes this camera this
camera or this camera let the people
know what you have going on in your life
a lot I can't even talk right now
Twitter IG just like
[Music]
from here to here all right right I
thought were they go doesn't [ __ ]
I'm straight too late too late oh but
then yeah we smoked you out there at the
end it was going on hot ones fans if you
like the video maybe meet us halfway
throw us a subscribe if you didn't like
the video don't subscribe I don't want
you I don't want you in the tent but if
you like the video subscribe thank you
very much I appreciate you I love you
more than a friend